you want to introduce yourself and tell
us what you do or tell the viewers what
you do i should say
sure um hi my name is nano um you
probably don't know who i am
but nice to meet you nice to meet you
guys very very humble start
i have to say you were the only reason
why i loved batum so much
yeah yeah zoom opening is so goddamn
good i'm just going to get that out of
the way
you know my song doesn't know your songs
oh really
yeah honestly from like that especially
batoon but out of everything about batum
i still remember the opening yeah to the
stage yeah to this day
wow and it's impressive because i don't
remember a lot about that show it's uh
it's been it's been many it's it's been
it's been many many years but i still
the opening just [ __ ] bang i just
gotta say i've gotta say that now that
and also arpeggio blue steel opening
is like so freaking good okay i do
remember that show being quite bad
but the opening though you know yeah
everything's banging even though i'm
really
i'm often mocked because i can't really
appreciate music but
i have to admit your music i like the
noise
that is an honor to hear that it's an
honor
so do you want to introduce yourself a
little to the viewers so they can learn
a bit more about you
well you know as they said um i've sung
a couple openings for anime uh
anime series series
using my words here um because talking
is not my
job so you know i mean yeah you you sing
sing
you have a much more lovely voice than
we do we just talk [ __ ] all day yeah and
that's our job
exactly but you know today is my uh sort
of youtube w days
oh wow oh you're debuting today yes so
maybe i'm gonna be a youtuber
youtuber from now on i did see you did a
youtube livestream at one point
i did i did i would love to do more
stuff on youtube so this today is sort
of my challenge day
and i'm really looking forward to so
uncovering
a new sort of me and you saw it yourself
yes exciting new adventure yeah exciting
the amount of pressure
exciting adventure that's going to be my
new uh song lyric oh wow
but yeah because i was curious like
obviously you've done
anime openings and you do uh your own
original music but how did you get your
start in that
ah that's a really long time you're
really gonna go there yeah yeah sure we
got the title we got the time let's just
jump right into it
i thought about looking at the wikipedia
page
the viewer and experience everything
about it yeah exactly
yeah that's great though so tom tells
everything yeah yeah don't don't go to
wiki
get your information from the real story
well i've always wanted to become a
singer since i was little but i started
off actually on the internet so
i was an internet singer i did a lot of
youtube right
that goes back way back to history um
even before all this like youtube boom
happened i was a youtuber well what year
what yeah what yeah i gotta ask
what year um way back when it's like 2
in like back when you had to favorite
the videos and give five stars
yes and like no matter what you did you
never got money for it
yeah that you know so back when it was a
four by three
yeah right aspect ratio oh oh gee
youtuber
brilliant is that when you started can't
i mean i started
kind of the beginning of youtube so yeah
like 2006 right
2007. so youtube launched in 2006 and i
made my first
it was late 2000's so um i was you know
just on youtube i did my own original
songs uploaded videos
and then i started you know japan
started sort of
getting into the um sort of movie
internet into like the culture of it so
you're
you're uh full japanese halftime
full japanese i was born and raised in
america my parents are both japanese so
i'm kind of a hybrid so bilingual as
well bilingual but i'd say i'm
like my roots are the stronger roots are
america
so i still find a lot of japanese things
really like
crazy insane
i mean we've talked about the weird
things we find about japanese culture
all the time
i'm sure i saw that video this morning i
watched it before coming here
so i'm good to go all right she did she
did all right so she did a research
she probably did more research than us i
feel bad now
well i mean i because like you know
connor's the kind of person who's like i
don't read the wikipedia i rather just
hear it from the person but like
i thought i would just dive slightly
into the wikipedia and kind of
ask you that's a lot that's the research
yeah yeah yeah
i'm psyched the wiki but like i'm the
kind of person who like goes to the
wikipedia and then
asks the person to confirm it if it's
true because yeah you know
a lot of times wikipedia is full of [ __ ]
yeah you know they just write whatever
the hell
yeah i don't think i've ever even
checked my own wikipedia because i'm
scared
we have we don't i don't have a
wikipedia i have like a youtube wiki or
something
the amount of misinformation on that is
just off the scale
um there's there's like there's like a
list of i think like
my best friends in order on their wiki
page and it's
it is like the most watched list i've
ever seen
because they're stuffed friends yeah
exactly but like i was looking at your
wikipedia
and one part one one aspect that i
thought was really interesting was how
you got started right
and it was like you started off by
covering anime songs
vocaloid songs and then really
specifically it said
covering avril lavigne songs
is this true well i've done a few of her
songs yeah
but i wouldn't say i'm a huge
afro-living cover
yeah yeah yeah i've done like two or two
songs yeah but like it's weird because
the wikipedia made it out to be like you
were like the ultimate
cover artist for avril lavigne it's
specifically
named alvaro levine along with anime and
vocaloids
i have an amber levine genre in my
wikipedia that's that's
for some reason yeah i mean like but
then again like you know
when i saw that i was like okay that
kind of makes sense because you know you
you kind of do have like a
very like early 2000s like avril lavigne
like but i do love her i
yeah i ended up listening to her music
but i wouldn't say i'm like
uh turning into an interrogation
that's really big for me but yeah yeah
yeah
so like what made you like upload your
first songs
were you just like passing time or did
you just was this your outlet
um well there was a time in my this is
pretty deep
it's pretty deep okay
where i was completely like introverted
i was a stay-at-home kind of person
even before all this um corona happened
covered 1990 i was a stay-at-home person
right there with you yeah i mean i mean
you're preaching to the choir now
yeah so this is like my generation right
now so yeah
um yeah during that time though i still
wanted to do music i still wanted to
reach out to people
so i thought you know oh yeah internet
great that's really
uh bendy yeah and
so i started uploading my own songs and
lo and behold i realized that there was
a huge crowd out in the world that i
could reach out to
right through the internet so that was
my start what was like your influences
for some of your early songs was it
mostly like anime and vocaloid or was it
just
or was it avril lavigne or was it i roll
the video oh yeah there you go
definitely can't live without her but
yeah definitely um i listened to a
lot of different types of music growing
up even from disney to
like british rock american rock anime
music j-rock
like i'm a huge widespread listener so
um
i wouldn't just narrow it down to one
genre or artist
right um yeah anime was a huge uh
start for me yeah because anime music
was
my introduction to the japanese culture
just like you guys yeah and so
yeah i mean what what confuses me almost
is
how do you go from doing covers to then
actually being the one singing the anime
opening what is that process
how do you go from there i'd like to ask
someone
to be honest if you don't know
who are just like if i just keep going i
might end up being the one singer right
that's the thing like you have to just
keep on doing it because that's what i
did and
you know whether you end up where you
end up
it's i don't know but if you don't
continue doing what you're doing
then you're never going to get so does
someone scout you or did you go
you know sending in auditions or like
what was the process like to i guess
even get
i guess recognized by a company or just
get signed i guess yeah
yeah before i started though i always
thought that you had to reach out you
had to go there and get it
yourself but if you keep doing the
things you do and you really enjoy
what you're doing then you're gonna
shine and people are going to listen to
you and people are going to notice you
so if it's if what you're doing is right
for you
then i think that someone out there is
going to find you
and in my case i was lucky enough to be
found by my director who
uh supported my debut so okay when was
this was this through youtube or through
nico nico
i mean it was through okay so nico nico
is like
japanese older version of japanese
youtube right was it focused on anime or
was it just everything it was like
vocaloids at the time
oh wow yeah i'm not a huge vocaloider to
be honest
um i wasn't even
like you know i wasn't that
knowledgeable about vocaloids but i was
just covering vocaloid songs in
english oh okay okay that was my big
start uh covering vocaloid science in
english so there weren't a lot of people
doing that
yeah you i don't think you have much
competition on nico nico because they're
like i think i think there's a small
dedicated community on youtube who
translates and does english song covers
of anime songs and
uh vocaloid songs but i've never heard
anyone posting on it on
nico nico mostly because nobody can
figure nico nico out yeah
there were like two people covering
vocaloid songs in english
but those people were not native english
speakers
i was listening to that and i thought
there could be something i could do
yeah um because i'm not that great at
japanese but i'm graded english so why
don't i just
do that in english and so um i started
doing that
and then the japanese people were like
oh this is new
they're like oh eggo jozu exactly
they're like why is that why is this
person
what's your toeic school